one of the many things you're known for
one of one of the big things is called
optogenetics what is it
optogenetics is a way of causing things
to happen it's a way of
determining what what actually matters
in terms of the activity of the brain
for
the amazing things it does
sensation cognition action
and what it does is it provides activity
it's a way of playing in if you will
activity patterns into precisely defined
cells and the way we do it is pretty
cool i think it's you know
right away there's a problem if you
think about how do we do this how could
we play in well-defined activity
patterns and provide a stream of
activity
into this cell and that cell and that
cell but not these other cells so just
for for context we're talking about the
brains of mice
uh monkeys
humans
and then the goal is to try to control
accurately the behavior of a single
neuron
and then to be able to monitor
a single
collection of single neurons to then say
well to draw some deeper insight about
the
origins first of all the function
of different parts of the brain
different neurons different kinds of
neurons but also the origins of the big
things the the flap of the butterfly
wing that leads to an actual behavioral
thing yeah so if you could exactly so if
you could turn on or off
the brain or parts of the brain or cell
types or individual cells
at the
natural rate and rhythm and timing of
normal brain activity
that would be immensely valid because
you could determine what actually
mattered what what could cause complex
things to happen and what could prevent
complex things from happening in a
specific way
but right away you've got a problem if
you want to do this and and scientists
neuroscientists have wanted to do this
for a long time francis crick of double
helix of dna fame he wrote a
famous paper in 1999 he got interested
in neuroscience later in life
and he said
what we need
in neuroscience is a way that we could
turn on or off
the activity of individual types of
neurons
in a behaving animal
and he even said
the ideal signal would be light because
it would be fast it could
penetrate through the
brain to some extent
and
he had no idea how to do it he said this
would probably be very far-fetched but
it would be a good thing and so that's
what you're actually saying like if you
want to do this kind of thing
and then
it's you imagine like how do i get
inside the brain it's pretty difficult
it's very difficult and then even once
you get in it's hard because all brain
cells are electrical all neurons are
electrically activated and so if you
wanted to use electricity
as what you were putting in
you won't have any specificity at all if
you have an electrode a wire and you put
it in the brain and you send current
through it
all
the cells near the electrode will be
stimulated it's like trying to control
fish by spraying them with water
yeah right because there's already a lot
of electricity going around anyway and
you're adding more but there's no
specificity even among the different
kinds of cells either because all around
the wire that you've put in they're
going to be so many different cells
doing totally different things many of
them in opposition to each other we know
that's one way the brain is set up there
are parts of the brain that
where neurons side by side are doing
completely different things and maybe
even antagonistic to each other
so what do you do how do you play in
activity with any kind of specificity
well
what you do is use what we found is what
you can do is
make
some cells responsive to light now
normally no cells deep in the in the
brain really respond to light they're
not built for that there's no reason for
them to respond to light in there
which is a great situation to start with
because any light sensitivity you can
provide to some cells will be a huge
signal above the noise
and so that's that's what we do with
optogenetics we take
genes bits of dna from
microbes single-celled organisms
and these single-celled organisms like
algae they
make
little proteins that sit on the surface
of their cells that receive light
capture a photon of light
and open up a little hole in the
membrane of the cell and let charged
particles ions like sodium and potassium
flow across the membrane of the cell
and that they these algae and bacteria
they do this for their own reasons
because that helps them move it helps
them
you make and use energy
but that's a beautiful thing for
neuroscience because movement of ions
charged particles across the membrane of
the cell is exactly the kind of
electricity that neurons work with so if
we can take this
bit of dna
that encodes this beautiful protein that
turns light into electricity from algae
and if we can put it into
some neurons but not other neurons which
we can do using genetic tricks
then you've got a situation then you can
shine on the light
and only
the cells that have the gene and that
are expressing the gene
will be the initial direct cells that
are activated by the light and so that's
the essence of optogenetics is the
ability to do that we get that initial
specificity that you could never get
with an electrode okay so let me say
that this is uh
we recently got uh the alaska prize for
this
is a brilliant idea
um
so i talked to um andrew huberman who's
a friend of yours friend of mine
um so not to jinx things but he believes
that he deserves the nobel prize for
this so
um
i do too but what uh my votes
anyway the thing is doesn't it doesn't
matter prizes will be all forgotten all
of us will be forgotten when the cool
idea is cool idea is a cool idea that's
a really powerful idea it's actually the
the origins of it you might be
interested in are even are very deep uh
there was a botanist in saint petersburg
named andrei femensin
in 1866
he published a paper
on the single-celled green algae and he
was the botanist who first noticed that
they moved in response to light these
are tiny single-celled algae that have
flagella so they swim through the water
and
he noticed this he was a botanist and he
published this it was as a paper you
know he wrote in
in german but he published it in a
french journal and he was doing it from
st petersburg so it was a very
international effort
but you have to go back to 1866 and that
i just i like to highlight how far back
the that discovery goes is back to andre
fleminson and this is a
it highlights the value of just pure
basic science discovery that always
originates uh somewhere in the eastern
european bloc uh but i don't think he uh
expected the splicing of genetic
material
yeah into the human brain and one of the
cool things we've been able to do now
with modern methods is to really study
these these proteins and so we we've
discovered some of these proteins other
other groups have as well we've dived
deep into their structure just like the
double helix structure of dna was
uncovered with x-ray crystallography we
used the same method x-ray
crystallography to see how these
beautiful little
proteins work we re-engineered them for
all kinds of function we can make them
instead of responding to blue light we
can make them respond to red light
we can speed them up slow them down we
can make them
with genetic engineering we can make
them have different ions flow through
them
and so it's it's this convergence as you
said like the botanist in 1866 couldn't
have predicted what we could do with
this uh and and the fact that we've been
able to discover how these beautiful
proteins work and then
uh apply them to neuroscience is really
a thrilling story is it possible to
achieve scale do you think with this
meaning
like greater like what is the progress
of the next 50 years 100 years looks
like in terms of the precision and the
scale of control of using light it's
going so fast it's hard to to predict
i'll i'll give you a sense of it though
in
you know
first paper you know
we published
in 2005 that was just in cultured
neurons by 2007 so that was in a dish by
2007 we had it working in behaving mice
by 2009 we had it pretty
general so we had methods to really make
it a versatile method it could be
applied to essentially any cell
by 2012 we could get to single cell
resolution we used light guidance
strategies to target individual cells in
the brain of a of a living mouse
by 2019
we were able to control up to
20 to 50 individually specified single
cells in the brain of a mouse and in
ways that specifically changed its
behavior that could bias its decisions
one way or the other in fact
we could take a mouse and
without any visual stimulus at all we
could make it act as if it had seen a
particular visual stimulus by playing in
using the single cell resolution
optogenetics
a specific pattern of activity into you
know 20 or 25 individually specified
cells that's 2019
to your question of scale now in 2022
we're controlling hundreds of
individually specified single cells
over
all the visual cortex of a mouse all the
part of the of the
of the brain that that is the initial
direct target of the incoming
information from the from the retina are
you constrained to specific types of
cells currently like you mentioned long
range is a little easier is there
constraints on which cells uh now there
really isn't now that we have this
individual cell guidance we can target
any individual kind of cell very
reliably um
and
so now to your question of scale
how far can we go well
things are moving quickly it's hard to
say
we can access individual cells across
the entire brain now
if you look 10 20 years in the future
um
you know i think we'll
we'll surprise ourselves but the fact
that we're already able to to cause
specific perceptions to happen and
specific actions means we're essentially
where we want to be and now it's a
matter of
just uh
you know
more experiments more discoveries but
the the basic
principles are clear now the basic
capabilities is there is there a pathway
to doing
the same for humans
optogenetics is primarily it's a
discovery tool it really is well suited
for use in mice and rats and and monkeys
because it's
it involves putting in a gene
uh and also delivering light and those
are two things that you can do in human
beings but you'd want to do
in a very careful way now that that said
there is actually just less than a year
ago
my friend botan raska in switzerland he
did the first human optogenetics
therapy
and he published this in the journal
nature medicine so about
uh
10 12 years ago he and i published a
paper together where we gave him one of
our
optogenetic tools one of these light
activated
regulators of ion flow
these are called microbial opsins by the
way opsins
and he put one of those into an
extracted retina from a human being uh
who had died so it was a catavaric
retina and he was able to show that
optical control in this in this paper
uh was able to turn on or off individual
cells in the human retina so that was a
while back
he spent about 10 years of going through
all the regulatory
you know hoops and hurdles and going
through primate studies and finally he
was able to take a human being
with a retinal degeneration syndrome so
someone who was blind in both eyes
and he gave a one of these options
into
one eye of this human being
who was blind
and
with the goal of conferring light
sensitivity onto this retina that
was not able to see light
and he was able to to make this person
see through that eye so he took a blind
person and the blind person could could
see now could reach for objects
selectively on a table uh
and
he published this in nature medicine and
it was
you know that's an amazing thing um do
you know the title of the pit what's his
name again roska r-o-s-k-a
can you look up the nature paper yeah
nature medicine and nature medicine so
that that's sort of proof of principle
now the retina is very accessible it's
near the surface you can use natural
light or you can use brighter natural
light
i'm myself
i see optogenetics as as a discovery
tool it's a way to figure out the
principles by which the brain works and
how it operates partial recovery of
visual function in a blind patient after
optogenetic therapy so he went through
the full process of
doing primate societies and then and
then going well that's dedication and
that that's really exciting to see
as beautiful as that is and i'm glad he
did all that work
there there are so many other ways that
optogenetics could help with therapies
once you know the principles
then any kind of therapy can become more
powerful once you know the causal cells
in a symptom like
in lack of motivation or inability to
enjoy things or altered sleep or altered
energy
once you know the cells that are causal
then you can make medications that
address those cells you could address
brain stimulation treatments that might
address those cells also diagnosis
very effective systematic way of
diagnosing or at least providing you
rich
data to some of these deep questions
about schizophrenia about bipolar all
those kinds of things that are
the tools are
low resolution currently for determining
what like the degree to which you have a
thing and whether you have a thing at
all
yeah and exactly and so the the hope is
you know that's a this is a great
example of how
you you can cure or you can you know
provide some relief for a symptom of a
person who has a serious degenerative
disease
but
but the principles are what what we're
after and
that's why i spend even though i'm a
psychiatrist even though i i still see
patients i'm not myself
trying to drive any clinical trials in
the lab
i'm trying to discover
and then
any kind of therapy could result from
that
you